our next story it was very interesting
to me a writer named ray fry at shape
magazine is a busy working mom who
realized that she and her husband hadn't
gotten busy in over a month
i was like oh is that a long time that's
a long time for a couple um they tried
to attack the problem with the 30-day
sex challenge
day one was awesome but day two the
bachelor was on day three someone had a
business trip day four her monthly bill
arrived early you get it so the boot
camp approach to making whoopee didn't
work instead they came up with these
easy to follow ground rules this is the
mapping number one put your phone away
number two figure out what time of the
day you like to steal the deal and if
it's early set that alarm make it happen
yep number three think outside the bed a
spicy location can help i like that one
i do like to i do like spontaneity
and then be intimate every day in some
way make out hold hands hug ah that
one's my favorite
and finally make sure to get to pleasure
town every single day whether it's a
solo mission or together
whoa okay 30 days every for 30 days yeah
thoughts
exhausting i know
it was awesome
i totally agree
all right gail your story
okay next we're talking about breakups
and if you're looking to heal your heart
we've got an interesting option
leo weekly reports for just three
dollars the kentucky
herpetological society will name an
insect after your ex and then
i know listen to that audience you can
feed it to a snake
the funds raised
will help support so you're doing this
for a good cause it sounds mean but
you're doing it for a good cause it's
going to help support all the reptiles
that live there do you have a name that
you would want to feed to the snake to
help fund them yep there is yep there's
someone yeah i have someone who
literally comes back into my life on the
regular basis for so many years i've
lost count and keeps going you know i
it's just it's just not the right time
for us i'm like are you kidding me
you've been calling me for 15 years
telling me it's not the right time for
us stop calling me and telling me
is this about the first breakup 20 years
ago
stop screwing with my head well i think
you said it right stop calling me so i
would like to name an insect after that
person and feed it to a snake and i've
already i've told them i told them
finally i said you ha i can't i won't
take your calls anymore
[Music]